[Music]
you might know Cameron Boyce as Carlos
from descendants but did you know that
he has a connection with Justin Bieber
or that he comes from an extremely
inspiring family stick with us until the
end to find out what's one of his
extremely surprising hobbies don't
forget to hit that notification bell to
never miss another video and be sure to
check out our community section for even
more fun now let's check out some
interesting facts about Cameron Boyce
networth okay let's clear out the one
question that's on everyone's mind just
how much is Cameron Boyce worth well the
short answer is quite a lot descendants
might be Cameron's best paid work but
he's been making a bank long before that
we'll talk more about some of his work
he did as a model and in commercials in
just a little bit yep you heard that
right
this kid's been keeping busy and books
reportedly his net worth stands at an
impressive five million dollars not bad
for a kid who made most of his money
before he turned 18 his fan mail address
in case you didn't know it's actually
very easy to reach Cameron although the
young actor isn't very much known for
his social media presence apart from
Instagram you can reach him through Dan
nel his fan mail address is actually
well known and confirmed by multiple
sources including his dad sure it's
snail mail but at least you know he'll
get it his official fan mail address is
4343 Lankershim boulevard suite 10
Universal City California 9 1 502 if you
could tell Cameron one thing what would
it be panic at the disco did you know
that Cameron has a connection to panic
at the disco check out their video for
their song the green gentlemen pay
attention to the small boy at the
beginning yep that's Cameron
doesn't he look absolutely adorable he
really was in the entertainment industry
since he was a kid
in 2014 dubbed Cameron who plays mal on
descendents tweeted how underrated Panic
at the Disco are the thin Victor Cameron
voices dad shared that green gentlemen
music video and said that they have some
great videos too adorable interaction
and a very deserved shout-out to the
iconic band impressive dance
skills seriously in case you only know
Cameron voice from The Descendants you
need to check out his other work he
really has impressive dance skills you
can actually find several videos of
Cameron breakdancing with his crew
called X mob he also had his teen on
Jesse where he was able to show off his
breakdance moves
Cameron even said that nothing makes him
feel as free as dancing he also said
that dancing is quite therapeutic and
you really learned to not care what
people think and just let it all go it's
no wonder he's so talented just look at
the way he talks about dance that's pure
passion he was in a Burger King
commercial Cameron voice was actually in
plenty of ads before he ever became a
part of the Disney family but did you
know he also appeared in a Burger King
commercial
he's the kid that's showing off his
super strength from eating a BK burger
he also appeared in another BK
commercial with transformers the movie
Cameron starred and plenty of other
commercials too that are well worth
checking out if you haven't seen them
yet Royal Wedding tributes seriously
this kid was born to dance
remember the Royal Wedding with Kate
Middleton and Prince William that was an
absolute huge worldwide event and many
people gave their tributes to the royal
couple
including Cameron he appeared on Dancing
with the Stars with Macy's stars crew
you can see him breakdancing at the
beginning of that scene but he's
featured throughout and he's doing some
serious acrobatics this happened back in
2011 and that means Cameron was around
11 years old those are some pretty
impressive moves for an 11 year old Luke
was created for him here's an
interesting facts you can actually find
an actual casting call for Jessie with
full descriptions of the characters the
show originally had in mind one of those
characters was a Korean kid named Hiro
Hiro is supposed to be very ill behaved
and he's supposed to love arguing with
his sister well you don't see a hero on
the show do you but you do see a Luke
Cameron himself said that the directors
actually changed his character to suit
Cameron's personality and look more and
to be fair we're so glad they did
because Luke is one of our favorite
characters on Jessie the
thirst projects Cameron isn't only
passionate about dance he also cares
about world issues he's a very known
ambassador of the thirst project which
focuses on providing people around the
world with safe drinking water Cameron
has actually been awarded the highest
honor from the project for donating over
27 thousand dollars the money was
actually donated by fans after Cameron
told them that he didn't want birthday
gifts or wishes he just warned his fans
to support this cause the thirst project
thanked him by presenting him with the
pioneering spirit award at the 2018
thirst gala justin beiber here's a
strange fact did you know that Cameron
Boyce has a connection with Justin
Bieber well it's a steamy connection
really Cameron actually appeared in
Justin Bieber's Never Say Never
documentary but if you want to find him
you'll have to watch the Director's Cut
version he's in it with Simran Claire
another talented dancer IMDB also lists
Cameron under the sound Department
category for Never Say Never a
documentary he's credited as a VR which
means he did some dubbing works to
improve the quality of the sound he
might not have met the Biebs but he most
likely worked with a lot of the behind
the scenes crew Young Artist Award
although he's been in the entertainment
industry for so long Cameron is just now
getting recognised for his hard work
we're sure this will all change in a few
years but until then let's celebrate his
wins and his nominations
Cameron won a shared Young Artist Award
for Best Performance in a feature film
in the 2011 Judy Moody and the knock
bummer summer movie he also got
nominated at the be TVA voice-acting
Award for his work on jake and the
neverland pirates while unfortunately he
didn't win we're sure his role in
descendants will bring him at least a
few Award nominations if not wins Best
Bud's one of the best things about
Cameron is watching him interact with
his fellow descendents cast mates
they're actually quite a close Bunch
well when you're together for three
movies you kind of have to get close
don't you but seeing pictures of this
cast just makes our hearts so warm they
call themselves the dream team
and they really are just go check out
Cameron's Instagram and scroll through
the pics we're sure they'll make you
smile not really a social media person
seriously Cameron is actually pretty
inspiring if you haven't noticed he's
not really a social media person sure
he'll post an Instagram picture here and
there but his Twitter account is usually
just linked to Instagram he doesn't
really post at all and all fans know
this Cameron actually said it himself
that he tries to be more alert but
whenever he catches him on Instagram he
puts down his phone and picks up his
guitar instead we should all take this
advice and spend less time on social
media Black History Month
Cameron is always speaking up on
important issues everyone should be
aware of in 2016
during Black History Month Cameron
shared a very inspiring story about his
grandmother who was one of the Clinton
12 she was one of the twelve black
teenagers that were the first ones to
attend Clinton high school after the
desegregation despite the intense
backlash from some of the white
residents of the school Cameron's
grandma and her friends continued to
courageously walk the hallways Cameron
said that his grandma has chosen to
forgive but never forget but the
students had to go through just for
being black spotted with on May 27 2018
Jessie fans got some serious nostalgia
feelings after Cameron posted the most
precious photo on Instagram we told you
his Instagram is a gold mine for behind
the scenes stuff on Cameron's projects a
day before his birthday Cameron posted a
photo with Karan and Peyton the jesse
cast still hangs out together even
though the show's been off the air since
2015 Cameron actually started a lunch
date tradition in 2017 when he asked
people to donate to the thirst project
and the birthday lunch date tradition
continued with his BFFs from Jessie
amazing family but it takes a village to
raise a child so it's safe to say
Cameron actually comes from a pretty
inspiring family if you're a hardcore
fan you're probably already familiar
with his dad's Twitter it's hands down
one of the most non embarrassing dad
Twitter accounts we have ever seen but
Cameron's other family members are doing
a good job to take his mother for
example Livie Boyce was actually praised
for her
and homelessness initiative before there
was even an official initiative launched
his sister Maya boyce actually got her
first acting role in camp rock she was
just seven years old Disney store
catalog did you know that you can find
young Cameron boys in a Disney Store
catalog it's no secret that Cameron is a
fantastic model because well have you
seen how gorgeous he is but when he was
young he was just too adorable check him
out doesn't he look cute we're telling
you this kid was made to be in the
entertainment industry and luckily for
him he also had a good head on his
shoulders along with his stunning looks
no seriously we can't get enough of this
adorable picture he's just too cute
dating rumors so let's get to the juicy
stuff who's this handsome man dating in
2017 Cameron announced that he doesn't
have a girlfriend
because it's hard to get one he also
said he's still getting better at
flirting there have been numerous rumors
that Cameron was dating one or all of
his descendants co-stars at some points
but he turned those down many are also
suspecting he had a relationship with
Sophie Reynolds and Brennan Domingo but
he's also denied those we've yet to have
an official confirmation on Cameron's
relationship status at the moment but
from what it looks like Cameron just
seems in love with life dancing and his
work for now target of an online hoax
the Internet is a strange place and
people come up with some of the weirdest
stories that end up circling around and
become viral Cameron was actually a part
of one of those stories one of the
online articles actually said that
Cameron passed away it was Dov who ended
up posting the article to The
Descendants cast a group chat of course
nothing happened to Cameron in real life
but it's a scary and confusing
experience to see a rumor about yourself
that's nowhere near the truth it's even
worse when that rumor states you're no
longer alive as you're actually reading
the text mixed ethnicity you've probably
guessed by now that Cameron's ethnicity
is pretty mixed but what exactly is he
well his father is african-american and
his mother is Jewish we've already seen
how incredible as upbringing was and
his family was able to really help him
grow up to be a hard-working and
passionate person his entire family is
absolutely inspiring we really can't
wait to see what's in store for this
talented actor but before we do we have
to talk about his hobby which is
actually pretty surprising fashion
designer along with being a model
Cameron has actually designed his own
fashion or better yet accessories
Cameron says that he absolutely loves to
create and he absolutely loves fashion
his whole idea is to create unisex
bracelets and a portion of their profits
will go toward causes he's passionate
about allegedly Cameron also likes to
design his own shirts and caps we're
telling you he's a force to be reckoned
with an actor a dancer and a fashion
designer and we're totally here for it
that's it for our video thanks for
watching
see you next time
[Music]